Hallo liebe Leute, und herzlich Willkommen bei einer neuen Episode von Cari antwortet!
Ich mache eine kurze Einführung auf Englisch, damit ihr weißt
dass dieses Video ohne Untertitel ist, wie alle andere 'Cari antwortet' Videos aber ihr könnt auf jedem Fall Untertitel beitragen
Eigentlich kannst du das als Muttersprachler, oder wenn dein Sprachniveau fast so gut wie Muttersprachler ist, und du beitragen möchtest
Bitte mach das hier auf Youtube, und schicke uns eine Email, nachdem du das getan hast.
Dann werden wir diese Untertitel veröffentlichen, die du gesendet hast. Schicke alle Emails zu info@easygerman.org
Jetzt wechsle wieder ins Deutsche
Also, ihr könnt die Untertitel so vielleicht in zwei oder drei Tagen anstellen.
Wenn wir welche bekommen haben, das werden wir in den Kommentaren posten.
Diese Woche haben wir kein Super Easy German Video für euch gemacht, denn wir sind tatsächlich mal wieder unterwegs,
und zwar sind wir diese Woche in Ghana, wo wir ein Video drehen für eine befreundete
Organisation und in dieser Zeit haben wir viel zu tun.
Aber wir dachten, wir machen zumindest ein kurzes Cari antwortet Video, denn wir haben schon wieder viele Fragen bekommen,
und haben sie lange nicht beantwortet
Unsere erste Frage ist heute von Daily reminder, er schreibt:
,,Cari, what dialect do you guys use? I thought it was the Berlin dialect"
Wir haben viele Kommentare bekommen zu unserem Video mit Emanuel von yourdailygerman.com
Wir haben ja ein Video gemacht über den Berliner Dialekt und viele Zuschauer waren geschockt
Dass der Berliner Dialekt so stark ist, dass es überhaupt ein Berliner Dialekt gibt
Und ja und haben zum Beispiel
Wie diese Person hier gefragt (hat)
Ob...ähm... welchen Dialekt wir eigentlich sprechen, wenn das nicht Berliner Dialekt ist und was wir eigentlich in den Videos sehen
Wir sprechen ja jede Woche mit Menschen in Berlin und ihr habt euch wahrscheinlich gefragt, welchen Dialekt sprechen diese Menschen
Der Berliner Dialekt wird nicht so stark gesprochen tatsächlich
er wird mehr außerhalb in den Randbezirken von Berlin gesprochen und auch manchmal nur in verschiedenen
sozialen Gruppen, also nicht jeder spricht das. Es hängt ein bisschen davon ab
Wo man aufgewachsen ist, ob die Eltern einem das beigebracht haben, ob man das auf der Arbeit spricht oder nicht
Und ihr müsst euch keine Sorgen machen
Wenn ihr nach Berlin kommt, werdet ihr fast alles verstehen, denn in der Innenstadt spricht man eigentlich immer Hochdeutsch
und Berlin ist ja auch 'ne Mischung mit Menschen aus ganz Deutschland, also sprechen die meisten
Hochdeutsch sowie übrigens auch in den meisten anderen Städten in Deutschland
Trotzdem in unseren Videos hört man manchmal den Berliner Dialekt, müsst immer darauf achten also vielleicht jede
zwölfte bis fünfzehnte Person hat einen leichten Dialekt, der nicht immer so ganz stark klingt, aber wenn ihr darauf achtet findet ihr den
Tlön schreibt: ,, Cari, ich möchte wissen, ob du diesen Dialekt verstehst"
Tatsächlich... ähm verstehe ich den Dialekt und
der ist auch relativ einfach zu verstehen im Vergleich zu anderen Dialekten. Es gibt Dialekten in Deutschland vor allem
im Süden von Deutschland, die in
Dörfern gesprochen werden, die ich manchmal überhaupt nicht verstehe und
Das passiert nicht so auf, weil es eben meistens in ländlichen Regionen so ist, dass dort ein starker Dialekt gesprochen wird
In den großen Städten wird eigentlich fast überall
Hochdeutsch gesprochen und auch ja sowieso überall Hochdeutsch
verstanden, also manchmal sind das dann eher so ein paar Worte oder so ein paar
Ein paar Unterschiede in der Aussprache, die man schon hört in München oder in Stuttgart aber nicht alle sprechen das so ganz stark
Jorge schreibt
With how regularity are German dialects spoken? I mean... Would I be able
to work and live normally
on a normal daily basis with standard German
Or should I be on my way to learn a German dialect, too?
Du solltest auf keinen Fall erst mal  irgendwie einen Dialekt lernen.
Du weißt ja noch vielleicht noch gar nicht wo du in Deutschland hinkommst
Standarddeutsch oder Hochdeutsch ist immer das womit ihr anfangen sollt denn ein Dialekt basiert ja auch auf Hochdeutsch
also gesprochen
wird fast immer bei der Arbeit in Hochdeutsch... wird auch in den großen Städten überall Hochdeutsch gesprochen, wird auch immer Hochdeutsch geschrieben
Also das was ihr in den Untertiteln gesehen habt
im Video mit Emanuel, das wird nie so geschrieben auch nicht fast nie in der Chat-Sprache so geschrieben. Also das haben wir mehr
Ja diese phonetische Transkription  haben wir eher gemacht damit, ihr das besser
nachvollziehen könnt und besser
hören, besser verstehen könnt aber
ansonsten müsst ihr euch keine Sorgen machen. Es gibt in Deutschland nicht ganz viele starke Dialekte und wenn, werden sie eher in
Kleinen Dörfern in den Kleinstädten gesprochen und das könnt ihr dann immer noch
Lernen wenn ihr da seid also da werdet ihr euch schon dran gewöhnen wenn ihr dann tatsächlich in einem bestimmten Dorf seid
Noch 'ne frage kommt von Larissa Gandhara
und da geht es um unser Video zum Thema:
"Are you proud to be German?" Sie fragt
Cari, bist du stolz
Deutsche zu sein?
Was eine sehr gute Frage ist und dieses ganze Video "Are you proud to be German?"
war ganz interessant weil das war natürlich ein bisschen provokativ gemacht. Es war auch ein bisschen click bait dahinter denn
diese Frage würde ich jetzt mit meinen Freunden nicht unbedingt diskutieren. Ich würde jetzt nicht fragen
Ich diskutiere jetzt nicht mit mit... irgendwie mit meinen Freunden darüber auf wir stolz darauf sein deutsch zu sein, weil
Das einfach für uns keine Relevanz hat. Wir können natürlich froh sein in Deutschland zu leben oder wir können
uns besonders typisch deutsch fühlen oder
etwas typisch Deutsches nicht mögen oder
etwas in Deutschland
mögen und nicht mögen. Ich mag sie sehr viele Dinge in Deutschland wenn mich jemand fragt ob ich stolz bin deutsch zu sein
Würde ich wahrscheinlich sagen ja und nein denn ich würde mich auf jeden Fall als deutsch
identifizieren und umso mehr ich reise, übrigens immer wenn ich in Afrika bin, in Asien bin, in Amerika bin dann
fühle ich mich plötzlich sehr deutsch weil dann erinnere ich mich plötzlich daran
Was wir in Deutschland alles machen, was so typisch deutsch ist, woran wir gewöhnt sind und so viele Stereotypen stimmen ja auch: dass
Deutsche Wert auf Pünktlichkeit legen, dass immer alles geordnet sein muss, dass ist auch so und ich mag das auch
Insofern mag ich viele Sachen in Deutschland. Ich mag dass wir eine gewisse
Grundstruktur haben, dass viele Sachen geregelt sind, dass man
viele Sachen direkt und ehrlich sagt und darauf bin ich in gewissem Sinne schon stolz oder darauf freu... darüber freue ich mich schon aber
Genauso gibt es Sachen, die ich eben scheiße finde in Deutschland und dazu gehört auch, dass viele Leute
Keinen vernünftigen Umgang mit unserer Vergangenheit haben. Das ist zum Beispiel eine Sache, die ich nicht mag
Denn es gab auch unter diesem Video sehr sehr viele hässliche
Kommentare. Die meisten davon habt ihr wahrscheinlich nicht gesehen denn wir haben sie ziemlich schnell gelöscht
Da waren Beleidigungen bei, da waren Sachen bei, die Leute geschrieben haben die einfach super hässlich waren
Und auch das ist eben Deutschland. wir haben jetzt zwölf Prozent unserer
Bevölkerung haben eine Partei gewählt die rassistische Äußerungen macht, ständig
Und ich finde das einfach eine Schande und auch peinlich für Deutschland dass wir 80 Jahre nach dem Nationalsozialismus jetzt wieder eine Partei
im Parlament haben, die
rassistische Sprüche macht und ja so was finde
Ich nicht gut und auch unter unserem Video haben wir so was gelesen wie "Wenn du nicht stolz auf Deutschland bist dann verpiss dich aus
Deutschland und die Frauen die gesagt haben dass sie nicht patriotisch sind- denen will ich ins Gesicht schlagen"
und solche Kommentare
standen unter unserem Video und nicht wenige, sondern viele und daran sieht man eben auch dass viele Leute in Deutschland
Nicht so einfach nicht so easy nicht so relaxt sind wenn es um dieses Thema geht und das finde ich doch ziemlich krass
Und viele Leute haben so ein bisschen Vorurteile
dass die Deutschen mit ihrer Vergangenheit nicht richtig umgehen können oder, dass die Vergangenheit sie davon abhält stolz zu sein
Aber ich ja ich finde empfinde das nicht so ich empfinde das nicht, dass das ein Problem darstellt, ich denke es ist eher
Wenn es etwas ist, dann ist es eher eine Bereicherung, dass die heutigen Generationen
Davon etwas gelernt haben denn
Diese ganze dieses ganze Thema war ja nicht
1945 vorbei, sondern das ist ein Prozess der sehr lange gedauert hat. Die Generation von meinem
Opa und meiner Oma- die haben den Krieg miterlebt. Die waren im Krieg, ob sie freiwillig oder unfreiwillig
Im Krieg waren. Sie haben einen gewissen Umgang gehabt und meistens haben sie darüber geschwiegen und haben darüber nicht gesprochen
Und die Generation von meinen Eltern die haben dann erst angefangen fragen
zu stellen in den 60ern, in den 70ern haben sie ihre Eltern gefragt
"Warum habt ihr das zugelassen? Was habt ihr im Krieg gemacht? Warum ist das passiert?"
und erst
20 Jahre später, 30 Jahre später sind diese ganzen Dinge aufgearbeitet worden
und dieser Prozess hält auch bis heute noch an, dass wir über gewisse Dinge nachdenken, dass wir über gewisse Dinge
mit gewissen Dingen einen
Anderen Umgang haben und einen anderen Zugang zu diesen Themen haben und ich finde das eigentlich ja gut dass wir
(über) ein paar Sachen doch wenigstens
reflektieren in dem Sinne
aber auch genauso schade, dass das eben nicht alle tun und ich würde mir eigentlich wünschen, dass
sich mehr Leute mit diesem Prozess beschäftigt hätten in Deutschland
Wieso ist überhaupt dazu gekommen ist und wie wir heute damit umgehen. Ja, das waren heute ein paar
Gedanken und ein paar Antworten an euch zu den Fragen, die ihr gestellt
habt. Ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen und ihr könnt mir immer mehr Kommentare schreiben, mehr fragen schreiben wenn ihr in
eurem Kommentar Cari - also meinen Name - reinschreibt und finde ich die Fragen schneller. Also schreibt ruhig immer eine frage wie
"Cari, was bedeutet dieses und dieses Wort?" dann
Nehme ich das in meine Liste mit auf.  Ich kann nicht alles beantworten aber ein paar Sachen beantworte ich immer gerne
Danke fürs Zuschauen und Sonntag seht ihr das nächste Video von uns
Das wird dann wieder eine kleine Überraschung von
einem anderen Ort in der Welt, nicht aus Ghana auf jeden Fall.
Bis bald und ciao!